it's a focus of this morning's ion money
segment every Tuesday we're going to
take a look at financial issues that
Americans face the media company
refinery29 has a series they call it
salary stories and this is where women
discuss how they negotiate their pay and
one of the installments in New York tech
professional shares how she started her
career making $40,000 a year now 11
years later she makes one hundred and
ten thousand dollars refinery29 sets
Julie Alvin joins us at the table she is
a one that helped develop salaries
stories good morning to you good morning
women everywhere I going Thank You Julie
Julie Julie I credit our working money
team for that yes
well thank you thank you money team and
Julie so why is this such a tough topic
for women why is it so difficult I think
there's a lot of sort of taboo around
the idea of speaking about money
and as we know women are less likely to
negotiate for their salaries they're
less likely to be successful with
negotiating their salaries women you
know we talk about the gender pay gap
and women are often likely to be paid
less for the same amount of why are we
so reluctant and hesitant to do that I
think that as women we aren't
necessarily comfortable talking about
our professional lives as candidly as we
should be I think that there's a lot of
sort of quiet and it can be awkward in a
work situation to really talk about how
much money you're making how you
negotiate it how you got where you are
and that's something that with salary
stories really looking to change and
give women the tools to negotiate to see
how other women got where they are in
their career study a study last year
found that that women actually asked for
raises as much as men they don't just
they don't get them Wow what do you
think that is so I think there's
competing information on whether they
ask as much or whether they are just
less successful when they ask and I
think there are a variety of reasons for
that so one that I find a purr to be a
particularly upsetting a piece of
information is that when men ask for
raises they're more likely to be seen as
assertive and you know go-getters and
women are more likely to be seen as
pushy as overly aggressive so energy
that's really a hair they're seen as
prepared and they're seen as you know
he's really advocating for himself
whereas women are more likely to be
penalized or seen in a less positive
light and that I think really bears
plays out when it comes to the actual
results of those negotiations because
women are often
less successful when they're negotiating
will be asked for it's not only a salary
conversation there's another survey that
found that men and women climb the
career ladder at different rates what's
behind that so I think that it's a
variety of things so one thing that I
think is particularly interesting is
women tend to only apply for a job when
they feel that they are 100% qualified
for it they meet 100% of the
requirements whereas men are totally
open to applying for those jobs when
they only meet 60% of the women should
be more like I I don't often say women
should be more like men I think women
have a lot of attributes that you know
we took the scales in a positive
direction but when it comes to this
women are less likely to have that
confidence in themselves and they're
more likely to say you know oh I'm not
quite there I don't want to waste my
time I'm gonna get rejected whereas men
see oh like you know I meet six I'm
gonna go for it
you make it thing so yeah how do we
change me what is your suggestion for
women who are listening to you right now
well I think that I think taking that
risk right I think saying okay maybe I
don't meet 100% of these qualifications
but I'm still going to go for it because
I am a valuable candidate and I'm
interested in this role going into
negotiations with a lot of information
on where they sit in the competitive
market and how much money they should
ask for is really important coming with
a list of your accomplishments how you
drove revenue how you drove growth and
being really prepared in that way and
also timing this timing and ask for a
promotion or in a goat or a raise with
you know you just came off of a really
big project and you have something
specific to point to and one thing
that's really interesting is women are
better at negotiating for other people
than they are for themselves so one idea
is to prepare a case for yourself as
though you were preparing for a
colleague who you want to advocate for
and that is something women are good at
is advocating for others so bringing
that sort of skill set to advocating for
yourself and looking at yourself sort of
more objectively yeah
rather than research on the best time of
day or the best time right after the guy
in the blenders forward
exactly I think that's a brilliant
strategy we gotta go Julie Alvin thank
you so much for being with us good
morning